so as those numbers continue to grow the
culinary union is now
adamant saying their workers are not in
safe conditions
now it's proposing a statewide mandate
to protect those they say are most at
risk
sasha loftis joins us now live from the
las vegas strip with the latest tonight
sasha
denise the union says since casinos
reopened in june
that hospitalization rates among its
members and their families
have gone up 860 percent some say they
are
scared to get sick at work but they have
to make money
now representatives are hoping to change
that he was such a happy big hearted
person irma fernandez pushes through her
pain
to share memories of her late father he
was strong and healthy
even if he even if he had
high blood pressure adolfo fernandez
died of covid19 complications last month
while working at caesar's palace my
father
will constantly tell me every day i know
i'm going to get sick
at work and this family is not alone
representatives say
since the pandemic began 352 union
members and their families have been
hospitalized
with 22 losing their lives we've been
letting know
all the leaders in the state about the
needs
they have that's why they proposed the
adolfo fernandez bill
to mende casino cleaning procedures and
social distancing
while also requiring temperature checks
and regular testing
i talking with people who have their
mother in
the hospital and
it's hot they hope their continued calls
for
change can now turn to concrete action
he
asked for help he could barely push his
heart
the last day he went to work so others
don't suffer from this same
tragic experience
union representatives say they have
contacted governor sissellac and other
state representatives to
get this bill in the agenda for the
special session at the legislature
we also reached out to governor
sisalek's office but have not yet
heard back for now reporting live on the
las vegas strip sasha loftis
8 news now